now last night we told you about the new
front being opened up by the bite
administration in the war on speech
and it seems that the dhs and the nsc
aren't the only government agencies that
want in
now it's the sec also known as the
security exchange commission
that has reportedly requested
information from a business partner of
donald trump's social media company
truth social now the filing could
reportedly materially delay materially
impede or prevent what is the
consummation of this business
combination over at truth social so we
decided to go to devin nunes ceo of
trump media technology group devin
um
what's going on here with the timing of
the sec's inquiry that you can share
with us tonight well you know laura
thank you i mean look we're all for
transparency here at true social trump
media group we don't have anything to
hide we'll answer any question that they
have and we want to be treated like
every other company you may remember
that it wasn't donald trump that needed
a new company
it was
only cause because donald trump was
kicked off of social media along with
those of us that were also shadow banned
or censored and everything else and look
it's always this thing where the left
always tells us well if you don't like
these social media companies big tech
companies you're conservatives
just go out and start your own company
well look that's what we're doing uh
donald trump didn't need a new company i
didn't need a new job we're trying to
open the internet back up for the
american people and give the people
their voice back and we expected to be
treated fairly like any other company
should be treated are you concerned at
this point with this inquiry about this
new business partnership of yours
uh that you're not being treated uh
fairly vis-a-vis other corporations that
don't have any association with
conservatism well look we don't know
because you know we filed publicly
everything transparent with the sec a
month ago
and they should be producing comments
that would be made public we'll answer
them all publicly
and remember the sec's charter is very
clear
it's there to protect the shareholders
and look the best thing to protect
shareholders is to have a speedy process
that gets done in in normal fashion so
that we don't have some bureaucracy yeah
weaponizing all branches of government
every agency in the federal government
is truly terrifying and we're paying for
it by the way now i want to play a
leaked video devin from uh project
veritas from elon musk
from yesterday's town hall with twitter
employees watch i think it's essential
to have a
free speech um and for and to be able to
communicate yeah just to communicate
freely in order for
people to have trust in twitter i think
it's extremely important that there'll
be transparency so the things that i
said about twitter i think are need to
happen um in order for it to be
you know to really go to the next level
devin would musk's twitter
acquisition be a threat
to the power of truth social
well actually uh president trump and
myself have been very clear we're all
for it right the mission of our company
is to open the internet back up and what
we've said from the very beginning you
know if elon musk can buy that company
plus instagram tick tock whoever he can
buy would be a hell of a lot better than
what we have today
and so you know look he's got a he's got
a tough job there it's not going to be
easy i mean that whole video was very
very strange i saw several of the
questions and i think it's going to be a
tough time because the people that work
there are just so woke and they don't
even understand what they're doing is
wrong you know and that's why look
yesterday and was very interesting we
had governor newsom of california join
true social and look i welcomed him
there now
newsome and i we haven't gotten you know
we don't agree on anything in california
but you know we're happy that he joined
i mean we want him to be there and he
put up a he put up a critical video of
republican policies what he believes are
our bad republican policies and that's
what it should be all about and look
that's what we're doing at true socials
we're letting everybody on we're not
censoring for political purposes um and
look and we're not going to kick
governor newsom off he's free to be
there and we invite other democrats to
join yeah well congressman there was all
these media reports that
you all were
booting people off truth social if
you know you're allegedly banning them
if they disagreed on issues regarding
january 6 the january 6th hearing
i'm going to give you the opportunity to
answer this is there any truth
to that claim again
it's actually zero so every day i mean
it's almost like i feel like we're back
in like the russia hoax like at the
height of the russia hoax where you get
95 stories a day that you don't even
have enough time in the day to dispute
them but this one was clear uh that they
were doctored
posts that went to twitter and then the
stupid fake news media went and wrote
stories so one writes a story then
another writes a story another writes a
story and it's like what the hell are
you talking about we couldn't find any
of it we looked for it couldn't find it
yeah i think it was actually good that
newsom came on joined truth social and
posted a video that's what the first
amendment's all about that's what our
country is all about having debates free
and open exchange of ideas
i thought that was a really great
development i i welcome that devin it's
great to see you as always thank you all
right thanks so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else